a menudo se refería a sí mismo como uno
de los papás de lucy es en
1974 en jada re tío pía cuando izco pan
junto a otros dos científicos descubrió
los huesos fosilizados de 32 millones de
años de un homínido un primo lejano de
la humanidad en 2018 explicó a france 24
como la colección de 52 fragmentos óseos
no sólo supuso un avance científico
sobre los ancestros humanos que
caminaban erguidos y trepaban a los
árboles sino que también inspiró a
varias generaciones
nos permitió por primera vez en el año
74 dibujar la silueta de uno de estos
pre humanos o de uno de sus antepasados
que con el nombre de lucy se hizo
presente en la mente de las personas y
los niños de una manera extraordinaria
se convirtió en la pequeña abuela de la
humanidad
nacido en bretaña copan dijo que desde
muy joven quería ser arqueólogo y a
partir de los años 60 viajo mucho áfrica
ya sean excavaciones aunque estos viajes
dieron lugar a muchos descubrimientos es
el desenterramiento de lucy lo que le
dio fama
la capacidad de copán de dar vida a su
campo para el público de todas las
edades contribuyó a despertar en
francia- el interés por las ciencias
galardonado con múltiples premios y
antiguo director del museo de la
humanidad de parís popa afirmó que
además de lucy lo que más le enorgullece
es haber descubierto un vínculo
irrefutable entre el cambio climático y
la aparición de la humanidad